LIKES THIS MASSUP HE HAD TWO
POINTS IN T MYERS.
SHOTS ARE 3-0, BUFFALO, EARLY,
AS SKINNER NEVER
THE SKINNER CHANCE WHERE HE JUST
MISSED THAT REBOUND.E WITH MILL.
.
AND JOKIHARJU,NT
AND PODKOLZIN ON THE REBOUND ANO
BEGIN THE SECOND PERIOD HE HAD
AND IT IS QUINN HUGHES STARTING
OUT, A MINUTE TO GO HERE IN POWR
PLAY AND MILLER ACROSS, NOW TO
ELIAS PETTERSSON, A SHOT AND
THAT TIME
AFTER THIS
GET WIPED OUT IF THE TIME
ANNOUNCEMENT. TIME TO
MITTELSTADT WHO SENDS I AND
DID NOT GET IT, THE FORWARDS
THERE, WITH
WATCHING THE
TO FREDERIC L'ECUY
OF HIS REACH AND HE KEEPS IT IN
AND THEN RETREATS HERE TO WITH U
STILL LIMITING THE FACT THAT HE
PUCK IN.KE TO SEE MOR TIME HORVT
TRYING A PASS TO BOESER, BROKEN
UP AND NOW THERE, GARLAND, THATO
DAHLIN AND NOW SAMUELSSON WITH
AN INDIRECT PAS THOMPSON
SET UP BY WITH JUULSEN THERE,
CHECKED IN THE CORNER AND IT STG
THIS.
GETTING THROUGH NOW TO
COZENS, KNOCKED OFF OF A
STICK, HONúGETTING THE WHISTLE.O
BOESER IN THE CORNER
AND A DISH TO BOESER.
STOPPED BY ANDERSON WHO
HAD COME OUT CHARGING TO GOT A L
GARLAND, STOPPED.
AND THEING THE PUCK
HERE WITH SPACE AND AROUND
BRYSON, CUTTING TO THE
NET AND NOW ANDERSON. WITH TUCH
WORKING OUT OFohn S.: THE GOALIS
SWITCH ENDS AND THEY
WILL GO THREE-ON-THREE
WITH HORVAT, MILLER AND
E-ON-THRE
EXCITEMENT WE WERE
PROMISED.
TUCH NOW, SHADOWED BY